-The FBI seized the phones
of two Trump aides
and issued 40 subpoenas,
as the Justice Department
intensifies its various
investigations of Donald Trump
and allies, including
MyPillow CEO Mike Lindell
whose phone was also seized
by the FBI.
For more on this,
it's time for a closer look.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's genuinely becoming very
difficult for me to keep track
of all the investigations into
Donald Trump and his allies.
For example, one of his closest
associates, Steve Bannon,
was just indicted for, I don't
know, like the 18th time.
The only was I'm able to keep
track is that he wears
a new layer of clothing for
every time he's been arrested.
It's like how you can tell
how old a tree is
by the number of rings it has.
By the time he actually ends up
going to prison,
he's gonna look like this.
And then we found out Trump's
fundraising activities
were also under investigation
for potential fraud.
-Blockbuster reporting from
"The New York Times"
that the Justice Department's
January 6th investigation
is expanding.
Quote, "A federal grand jury has
issued subpoenas seeking
information about
Save America PAC,
which was formed
as former President Trump
promoted baseless assertions
about election fraud."
As a reminder, Trump created
the Save America PAC
after he lost the 2020 election.
He raised millions of dollars
by falsely claiming
that there was rampant voter
fraud that had to be stopped.
And according to
the January 6th Committee,
Trump and his surrogates
mislead donors
about what their PAC donations
would ultimately be used for.
-You mean to tell me
Donald Trump
has amassed a giant pile of
money that might not entirely
be above board?
[ Laughter ]
Next you're gonna tell me
Chris Pine wasn't thrilled to be
at the Venice Film Festival.
And in particular, what seems to
have attracted the attention
of the feds, in Trump's case, is
that he seems, and I know
this will come as a shock, to
have lied to his supporters
to get their money.
Although, let me stress, I think
most people who donate money
to Trump would do it no matter
what he said it was for.
I don't know why he opened
himself up to criminal liability
by lying and saying it was
for a legal fund
when he could've
just raised as much
from telling his supporters...
Or...
[ Applause ]
So those are just a few
of the newest revelations
we've learned about recently.
And as I said earlier,
it's getting hard to keep track
of all of Trump's criminal
investigations.
I mean, I don't even think
I could list them all here
if I tried, which is a shame
because people should know
about all of them, given that
the Republican Party
and so many of its midterm
candidates are standing
firmly behind Trump.
I just wish someone would put
all the Trump scandals
into -- I don't know, one giant
list so we could get a sense
of Trump's corruption.
I mean, maybe some young hotshot
journalist dead set on
taking down the former president
and the whole Conservative
establishment.
Maybe someone like this man.
-First, it was the Russia hoax,
then it was Comey's
Crossfire Hurricane,
Mueller's witch hunt,
the Emoluments Clause
investigation
from the House Oversight
Committee,
a House Ways and Means
investigation
into Trump's taxes,
another House investigation into
Trump's hotel lease,
foreign gift disclosures,
a D.C. probe into Trump's
inauguration fundraising,
another similar investigation
from the Southern District
of New York,
and the Eastern District
and from New Jersey's
attorney general,
one impeachment investigation
into a regular phone call
with Ukraine,
a second impeachment
investigation into January 6th,
yet another House Committee
investigation into January 6th
that is still ongoing with more
hearings to come.
And then there's the Southern
District of New York's
investigation into pardons,
a DOJ probe into Trump's
political action committee,
another House investigation into
the Trump Administration's
security clearance process,
other investigations into
Trump's property valuations,
and of course his social media,
Truth Social,
the Trump Foundation, as well
as a variety of other
tax investigations,
and of course the
National Archives investigation
that lead to the Mar-a-Lago
raid.
You got all that?
-Mar-a-Lago raid.
I do now!
I got it all now.
[ Applause ]
[ Laughs ]
Also those weren't his hats.
Seriously, was that list
supposed to make anyone
other than Donald Trump
look bad?
It's like a reverse résumé where
you list all the reasons
you've been fired
from previous jobs.
Uh, special skills?
Let's see.
I'm often late,
I steal office supplies,
I ask co-workers on dates,
and won't take no for an answer,
I treat every day
like casual Friday
and every Friday
like underpants Sunday.
And when I'm given feedback
on my work,
I have been known
to pull a knife.
And now I've a question
for you -- when do I start?
[ Laughter ]
Don't make me pull my knife!
He has somehow, as of today --
there is still yet more
to add to that list, because in
addition to the House hearings
into January 6th,
there are multiple
criminal investigations,
including multiple federal
grand juries that we know of.
And now, one of those
investigations taking yet
another extraordinary step
by seizing the phones
of two Trump aides and issuing
a flurry of subpoenas.
-"The Times" reports,
"Justice Department
officials..."
-40 subpoenas!
Next time Hannity does his list
of Trump investigations,
he's not even gonna be able
to get to all of them,
he's just gonna have to read
every fourth entry
as it scrolls by and call it
"Now That's What I Call A Trump
Criminal Investigation"
or "Jerk Jams".
Feel like one of those.
And by the way, those are just
the investigations
and subpoenas that are directly
related to Trump's
personal actions
to overturn the election.
Then there are the satellite
figures floating in his orbit
who tried to help out
in their own ways
and now face
their own legal trouble,
like MyPillow CEO Mike Lindell.
And again, I always feel like
I need to clear this up.
The name of his company is
MyPillow,
he's not my pillow CEO.
My pillow CEO is a guy named
David Rosenbaum,
who does a fantastic job.
Started with 15 pillows, I think
we're up to like 19, 20.
And before we get to the Lindell
news, I also think it's worth
pausing to reflect on the fact
that one of the president's
closest outside aides
and advisers
was a guy who sells [Bleep]
pillows.
That in itself is not
a good sign.
President Obama literally had
a Nobel laureate
in his cabinet.
I don't remember Obama ever
taking the mic
at a press conference
and saying,
"And now, I'd like to introduce
the man who'll be spearheading
our national infrastructure
plan,
the ShamWoW guy."
[ Laughter ]
Now Lindell, of course, already
posted about this story online,
as you might expect.
And just as entertaining as
the news itself is the location
where it happened.
-Today, the FBI -- you're gonna
hear this, and you're probably
already hearing it in the news.
The FBI came after me and took
my phone, they surrounded me
at a Hardee's,
and took my phone
that I run all my business,
everything with.
They could've just -- what
they've done is weaponized
the FBI.
It's disgusting.
I don't have a computer.
Everything I do -- that phone,
everything was on there.
And they told me not
to tell anybody.
Here's an order not to -- don't
tell anybody.
Okay, I won't. [ Chuckles ]
But I am.
So, there you go.
-It's so fitting that they stop
Lindell at a Hardee's,
because when you think of it,
Hardee's would be
a more accurate name
for MyPillow.
[ Laughter ]
And to be clear, Lindell says it
was at the drive-thru
at a Hardee's near
Mankato, Minnesota.
It's just so perfect.
I think if someone told you,
"Hey, they seized Mike Lindell's
cellphone," your brain would
just auto-complete the sentence
with, "At a Mankato Hardee's."
It's also great because
Lindell's regular
speaking volume is
everybody else's
ordering at
a drive-thru volume.
[ Imitating Lindell ]
"They surrounded me
at a Hardee's,
and at first I thought
they were gonna take my order,
so I said, 'Okay, I'll have
97 orders of biscuits.'
But then they told me they were
with the FBI,
and I said, 'Does that stand for
Federal Biscuit Inspectors?'
And they said, 'That's not
a thing.'
And I said, 'Well, it should be
because sometimes the biscuits
are too dry.'
And they said, 'Don't tell
anybody.'
And I showed them that.
And that's not the one.
Where'd the thing go?
I don't have a computer."
[ Normal voice ] I also --
[ Cheers and applause ]
I also love to imagine Lindell
only eats at restaurants
and towns that are fun to say
in his voice.
[ Imitating Lindell ] Where you
guys want to go eat?
We could go to the Hardee's in
Mankato, or the Arby's
in Owatonna, or maybe
the Jack in the Box
in Oconomowoc.
[ Normal voice ] So that's
Lindell's side of the story.
Although, if you want to hear
more of it,
you'll apparently have to into
a network other than Fox News,
because when they reported
on this story last night,
they briefly played a clip
of Lindell explaining
the situation just before
cutting him off.
-FBI agents located him,
questioned him,
showed him their badges,
and asked him questions
about Colorado and Dominion
voting machines,
and then provided him
with a warrant
to seize his cellphone.
-And then he says, "We're FBI."
I said, "Show my your badges."
So they show one badge, I said,
"How about yours?"
You know, 'cause I don't trust
anybody, like, you know,
there's bad people.
Well, they do that, and I say,
"Well, what do you want?"
And they said, "We need to talk
to you."
So I pull over, and --
-Mike Lindell said that he
initially told those agents
he would not surrender his
phone, because he does not
have a computer and runs all
of his businesses
off of that phone.
-[ Imitating Lindell ]
Where's my camera? Over here?
Okay, ready to go with my story
about the FBI.
We're filming this in my office,
so I think I know
where the camera is.
[ Normal voice ] They just cut
him off the way you hang up
on your grandpa over FaceTime.
Hi!
Hi, grandpa.
I heard you met a friend today,
what did he say?
-He says, "We're FBI."
I said, "Show me your badges."
So they show one badge, I said,
"How about yours?"
You know, 'cause I don't trust
anybody, you know, like,
there's bad people.
Well, they do that, and I say,
"What do you want?"
And they say,
"We need to talk to you."
So I pull over --
-Okay, grandpa, gotta go.
The FBI is seizing my phone.
Bye.
Although, my favorite part
of the Fox News coverage
came earlier when Fox host
Tucker Carlson introduced
the news in a very solemn tone,
but also, for some reason,
threw in a dig at Lindell.
-This is a Fox News alert
and a shocking one.
We told you last night that
the Biden Administration
has politicized law enforcement
to the point
where it feels Soviet.
And we were not overstating it.
The FBI has just raided the guy
who sells pillows
on this channel, not because
the pillows were bad,
but because they don't like
who he voted for.
-I love how he makes it sound
like he would've been totally
fine with it,
if they had raided Lindell
because his pillows were bad.
Way to be a pal.
If you're gonna raid
this truth-telling,
democracy-loving patriot
for anything,
let it be for how criminally
uncomfortable
his [Bleep] ass pillows are.
[ Imitating Lindell ] Hey,
Tucker, I'm standing right here.
[ Normal voice ] As midterm
election season intensifies,
Republican candidates cross
country made it clear
that they are not only okay
with actively supporting
Trump's corruption, his attempts
to dismantle democracy,
which is why it's so important
the Justice Department follow
every lead and investigation
every accomplice, even if it's
just three guys or four guys
or five guys, they have to
follow the dominoes,
even if they lead all the way
to...
-Hardee's.
[ Laughter ]
-This has been a closer look.
♪♪
The midterm elections
are coming up,
so to make sure
that you're good to vote
in this election,
visit our good friends
at headcount.org to check
your voter registration status
or to register to vote.